let's say we've got the function f of x
is equal to the natural log of x to the
fourth
plus 27 and what we want to do is take
its first and second derivatives and use
as much as we
of our techniques as we have at our
disposal to attempt to graph it without
a graphing calculator if we have time
i'll take out the graphing calculator
and see if if our answer matches up so a
good place to start is to take the first
derivative of this so let me do that
over here so
the derivative
of f
well you take the derivative of the
inside so take the derivative of that
right there which is
4
x to the third and then multiply it
times the derivative of the outside with
respect to the inside so the derivative
of natural log of x is one over x so the
derivative of this whole thing with
respect to this inside expression is
going to be so times one over
x to the fourth
plus 27 if you found that confusing you
might want to rewatch the chain rule
videos but that's the first derivative
of our function and i could rewrite this
this is equal to 4
x to the third
over
x to the 4th plus 27 or i could write it
as 4 x to the third times x to the
fourth plus 27 to the negative 1. all
three of these expressions are
equivalent i'm just
writing i've multiplied it out or i
could write this as a negative exponent
or i could write this as a a fraction
with this in the denominator they're all
equivalent so that's our first
derivative let's do our second
derivative
our second order this looks like it'll
get a little bit
this will get a little bit hairier so
our second derivative is the derivative
of this
so it's equal to we can now use the
product rule it's the derivative of
this first expression times the second
expression so the derivative of this
first expression 3 times 4 is 12
12
x squared right we just decrement the
three by one times the second expression
times
x to the fourth plus 27 to the minus one
and then to that we want to add
we want to add just the first expression
not its derivative so just 4x to the
third times the derivative of the second
expression in the derivative of the
second expression we could take the
derivative of the inside which is just
4x to the third this derivative of 27 is
just 0
so times
4x to the third
times the derivative of this whole thing
with respect to the inside so
time so you get take this exponent put
it out front so times
minus 1
times this whole thing
x to the fourth
plus 27
to the we decrement this by one more so
minus 2. so let's see if i can simplify
this expression a little bit
so this is equal to
so this right here is equal to
12
x squared
over this thing
x to the fourth plus
27 and then let's see if we mult we're
gonna have a minus here so it's minus
you multiply these two guys four times
four is sixteen
sixteen x to the third times x to the
third is x to the sixth
over this thing squared over
x to the fourth
plus 27
squared that's just another way to
rewrite that expression right there
right to the minus two you could just
put in the denominator and make it to a
positive 2 in the denominator same thing
now if you you've seen these problems in
the past we always want to set these
things equal to 0. we want to solve for
x equals 0. so it'll be useful to have
this expressed as just
one fraction instead of the difference
or the sum of two fractions so we could
do is to have we could have a common
denominator so we could multiply
both the numerator and denominator of
this expression by x to the fourth plus
27 and what do we get so this is equal
to so if we multiply this first
expression times x to the fourth plus 27
we get
12
x squared times x to the fourth plus 27
and then in the denominator you have
x to the fourth
plus 27
squared all i did i multiplied this
numerator and this denominator by x to
the fourth plus 27 i didn't change it
and then we have that second term
minus 16
x to the sixth
over
x to the fourth plus 27
squared the whole reason why i did that
now i have a common denominator now i
can just add the numerators so this is
going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to let's see
let's multi well the denominator we know
the denominator is
it is x to the fourth plus 27
squared that's our denominator and then
we can multiply this out this is 12x
squared times x to the fourth so that's
12
x to the sixth plus 27 times 12. i don't
even feel like multiplying 27 times 12
so i'll just write that out so plus
27 times 12
x
squared i just multiply the 12x squared
times 27
and then minus 16x to the sixth
minus 16 x to the sixth
and this simplifies to let's see if i
can simplify this even further so i have
an x to the sixth here x to the sixth
here so this is equal to do this in pink
this is equal to the 27 times 12x
squared i don't feel like figuring that
out right now
times 12
x squared and then you have minus 16x to
the 6 and plus 12x to the 6. so you add
those two you get minus 4. 12 minus 16
is minus 4
x to the sixth
all of that
over
x to the fourth plus
27
plus 27
squared
and that is our second derivative now
we've done all of the derivatives and
this was actually a pretty hairy problem
and now we can set we can solve for when
the first and the second derivatives
equal zero
and we'll have our candidate well we'll
know our critical points and then we'll
have our candidate inflection points and
see if we can make any headway from
there so first let's see when where our
first derivative is equal to zero and
get our critical points or at least
maybe also maybe where there where it's
undefined
so this is equal to zero if we want to
set if this the only place that this can
equal to zero is if this numerator is
equal to zero
this denominator actually
if we are assuming we're dealing with
real numbers this term right here is
always going to be greater than or equal
to 0 for any value of x because it's an
even exponent so this thing can never
equal 0 right because you're adding 27
to something that's non-negative so this
will never equal 0. so this will also
never be undefined so there's no there's
no
undefined critical points here but we
could set the numerator equal
to 0 pretty easily
if we wanted to set this equal to 0 we
just say 4
x to the third is equal to zero and we
know what x value will make that equal
to zero x has to be equal to zero four
times something the third is equal zero
that something has to be zero x to the
third has to be zero x has to be zero so
we can write f prime
of 0 is equal to 0. so 0 is a critical
point
0 is a critical point
critical point the slope at 0 is 0. we
don't know if it's a maximum or a
minimum or an inflection point yet or i
mean it could be a
you know
well we'll explore it a little bit more
and actually just so we get the
coordinate what's the coordinate the
coordinate x is 0
and then y is the natural log if x is 0
this just turns out so it's a natural
log of 27 so it's the natural log of let
me figure out what that is and get the
calculator out i said i wouldn't use a
graphing calculator but i could use a
regular calculator so 27 if i were to
take the natural log of that it's like
three point well for our purpose let's
just call it three point three we're
just trying to get the general shape of
the graph so three point three
three
point well we could just say two nine
and it keep it kept going
so this is a critical point right here
the slope is zero here
slope
is equal to zero
at x is equal to zero so this is one
thing we want to block off and let's see
if we can find any candidate inflection
points and remember candidate inflection
points are where the second derivative
equals zero now the second derivative
equals zero that doesn't tell us that
those are definitely inflection points
let me make this very clear
if
let me write this let me do it in a new
color if
x is
inflection
inflection
then
then the second derivative at x is going
to be equal to zero because you're
having a change in the concavity i
always say concativity but it's a
concavity you have a change in the the
slope goes from either increasing to
decreasing or from decreasing to
increasing but if the if the derivative
is equal to zero you cannot the second
derivative is equal to zero you cannot
assume that is an inflection point so
what we're going to do is we're going to
find all of the points at which this is
true
at which this is true and then see if we
actually do have a sign change in the
second derivative of that point and only
if you have a sign change then you can
say it's an inflection point so let's
see if we can do that so just because
the second derivative is zero that by
itself does not tell you it's an
inflection point it has to have a second
derivative of zero and
when you go above or below that x you
have to the the second derivative has to
actually change signs only then so we
can say if
f prime changes
changes
signs
around
around x then we can say that x is an
inflection
x is inflection
and if it's changing signs around x then
it's definitely going to be 0 right at x
but you have to actually see that if
it's negative before x has to be
positive after x or if it's positive
before x has to be negative after x
let's test that out
so the first thing we need to do is find
these candidate points remember the
candidate points are where the second
derivative is equal to zero we're going
to find those points and then see if
this is true that the sign actually
changes so we want to find
where this thing over here is equal to
zero
and once again for this to be equal zero
the numerator has to be equal to zero
this denominator can never be equal to
zero if we're dealing with real numbers
which i think is a fair assumption so
let's see where this where this
where the where our numerator can be
equal zero for the second derivative
so let's set the second derivative the
numerator of the second derivative 27
times 12
x squared minus 4x to the sixth is equal
to zero remember that's just the
numerator of our second derivative any x
that makes the numerator zero is making
the second derivative
0.
so let's factor out a let's factor out a
4 x squared
so 4 x squared
now we'll have 27
times if we factor 4 out of the 12 we'll
just get a 3 and we factored out the x
squared
minus we factored out the 4 we factored
out an x squared so we have x to the 4th
is equal to 0.
so the x's that will make this equal 0
either will satisfy either i'll switch
colors
either 4 x squared is equal to 0 or now
27 times 3 i can do that in my head
that's 81 20 times 3 is 60 7 times 3 is
21 60 plus 20 was 81 or 81 minus
minus x to the fourth is equal to zero
any x that satisfies either of these
will make this entire expression equal
to zero because if this thing is zero
the whole thing is going to equal zero
if this thing is 0 the whole thing is
going to equal 0. let me be clear this
is 81 right there so let's solve this
this is going to be 0 when x is equal
when x is equal to 0 itself
this is going to be equal to 0 when x
let's see if we add x to four to both
sides you get x to the fourth is equal
to eighty-one if we take the square root
of both sides of this you get
x squared is equal to nine
or so you get x is plus or minus three
x is equal to
x is equal to plus or minus three
so these are our candidate inflection
points x is equal to zero x is equal to
plus three or x is equal to minus three
so what we have to do now is to see
whether the second derivative changes
signs around these points in order to be
able to label them inflection points so
what happens when x is slightly below
zero
so let's let's take the situation let's
do all the scenarios what happens when x
is slightly below zero not all of them
necessary but if like x is like point
one what is the second derivative going
to be doing if x is point one
this or if x is minus 0.1 this term
right here is going to be positive
and then this is going to be 81 minus
0.1 to the fourth so that's going to be
a very small number right so it's going
to be some positive number times 81
minus a small number so it's going to be
a positive number so when x is less than
zero or just slightly less than zero
our second derivative
our second derivative is positive now
what happens when x is slightly larger
this isn't when i write this notation i
want to be careful i mean really just
right below 0.
now when x is right above 0 what happens
let's say x was .01 or 0.1 positive 0.1
what's going to be the same thing
because in both cases we're squaring and
we're taking the fourth so you're kind
of losing your sign information so if x
is 0.1 this thing is going to be a small
positive number you're going to be
subtracting a very small positive number
from 81 but 81 minus a small number is
still
going to be positive so you're gonna
have a positive times a positive so
your second derivative is still going to
be greater than zero so something
interesting here
f at
your second derivative
is zero when x is equal to zero but it
is not an inflection point because
notice the concativity or sorry the
concavity did not change around zero our
second derivative
is positive as we approach zero from the
left and it's positive as we approach
zero from the right
so in general at zero we're always as we
as we need as we're near zero from
either direction we're going to be
concave upwards so the fact that
the fact that 0 is a critical point and
that we're always concave upward as we
approach 0 from either side
this tells us
that this is a minimum point
minimum
minimum point right there because we're
concave upwards all around zero so
that's our so zero is not an inflection
point let's see if positive and negative
three are inflection points
and if you study this equation let me
let me write our
and actually i just want to be clear
i've just been using the numerator of
the second derivative the whole second
derivative is is this thing right here
but i've been ignoring the denominator
because the denominator is always
positive so if we're trying to
understand whether things are positive
or negative we just really have to
determine whether the numerator is
positive or negative because this
expression right here is always positive
it's something to the second power
so let's test whether we have a change
in concavity around x is equal to
positive or negative 3.
so remember the numerator of our let me
just rewrite our second derivative just
so you see it here f prime prime of x
the numerator is this thing right here
it's 4 x squared times 81
minus x to the fourth and the
denominator was up here
x to the fourth plus 27 squared
x to the fourth plus 27
squared that was our second derivative
let's see if if this changes signs
around positive or negative three and
actually we should get the same answer
because
regardless of whether we put positive or
negative 3 here you lose all your sign
information because you're taking it to
the fourth power you're taking to the
second power and obviously anything to
the fourth power is always going to be
positive anything to the second power is
always going to be negative so kind of
when we do our test if it's true for
positive 3 is probably going to be true
for
negative 3 as well but let's just try it
out so when x is
just a little bit less than positive 3
what's the sign of f prime prime of x so
it's going to be 4 times
times 9 so you know or it's going to be
4 times a positive number it might be
like 2.999 but this is still going to be
positive so this is going to be positive
when x is approaching 3
and then this is going to be well if x
is 3 this is 0 so if x is a little bit
less than 3 if x is a little bit less
than 3 if it's like 2.9999
this number is going to be less than 81
so this is also going to be positive and
of course the denominator is always
positive so as x is less than three is
approaching from the left we are concave
upwards this thing is going to be a
positive then f prime prime is greater
than zero we are upwards
concave upwards
when x is just larger than 3 what's
going to happen well this first term is
still going to be positive but if x is
just larger than 3 x to the fourth is
going to be just larger than 81 and then
so this second term is going to be
negative in that situation
it's going to be negative
let me do it a new color
it's going to be negative when x is
larger than 3 because this is going to
be larger than 81.
so if this is negative and this is
positive then the whole thing is going
to be negative because this denominator
is still going to be positive so then f
prime prime is going to be less than
zero so we're going to be concave
downwards
one last one
what happens when x is just greater than
minus three
so just being greater than minus three
that's like minus two point nine nine
nine nine nine so when you take minus
two point nine nine and square it you're
gonna get a positive number so this is
gonna be positive
and if you take minus 2.99 to the fourth
that's going to be a little bit less
than 81 right because 2.99 to the fourth
is a little bit less than 81 so this is
still going to be positive
so you have positive times a positive
divided by a positive so you're going to
be concave upwards because your second
derivative is going to be greater than 0
concave upwards
and then finally when x is just
just
less than negative 3. remember when i
write this i don't mean for all x's
larger than negative three are all x is
smaller than negative three i really uh
i there's actually no well i can't think
of the notation that would say just as
we just approached three in this case
from the left but what happens if we
just go to minus three point one one or
you know 3.01 i guess is a better one or
3.1 well this term right here is going
to be positive but if we take minus 3.1
to the fourth
that's going to be up that's going to be
larger than positive 81 right the sign
will become positive it'll be larger
than 81 so this will become negative
so in that case as well we'll have a
positive times a negative divided by a
positive
so then
our second derivative is going to be
negative and so we're going to be
downwards
downwards so i think we're ready to plot
so first of all r is x plus or minus
three inflection points sure as we
approach x is equal to three from the
left we are concave upwards and then as
we cross three we the second derivative
is zero the second derivative zero i
lost it up here the second derivative is
zero
and then as we go to the right of three
we become concave downwards so we got
our sign change in the second derivative
so x is equal to three so this three is
definitely inflection point and the same
argument could be made for negative
three we switch signs as we cross three
so these definitely are
inflection points
in flexion just so we get the exact
coordinates let's figure out what f of 3
is or f of positive and negative 3 and
then we're ready to graph
so first of all we know that f we know
that the point 0 comma 3.29
that this was a minimum
because zero was a critical point the
slope is zero there and because it's
concave upwards all around zero so zero
is definitely not an inflection point
and then we know that the points
positive three and minus three are
inflection points and in order to figure
out their y-coordinates we can just
evaluate them
so they're actually going to have the
same y-coordinates because if you put a
minus 3 or a positive 3 and take it to
the fourth power you're going to get the
same thing let's figure out what they
are
so if we take three to the fourth power
that's what 81
81
plus 27 is equal to 108 and then we want
to take the natural log of it we're
going to take the natural log
it's like four point let's just say four
point seven just to get a rough idea
four point seven
and that's true of whether we do
positive or negative three because we
took to the fourth power so it's 4.7
4.7
these are both inflection points
and we should be ready to graph it let's
graph it
all right let me draw my axis
let me draw my axis just like that
and then this is my y-axis
so this is my x-axis this is y or you
could even call it the f of x-axis if
you like
this is x and so the point 0
3.29 so let's say this is 1 2
3
four
five
so the point zero three point two nine
so that's zero one two three a little
bit above three is right there that's a
minimum point
and then we're concave the slope is zero
right there we figured that out because
it was a the first derivative was 0
there so it's a critical point and it's
concave upwards around there so that
told us we're at a minimum point
right there
and then
at
positive 3. so 1 2 3 at positive 3
4.7 so 4.7 will look something like that
we have an inflection point before that
before that were concave upwards and
then after that were concave downward so
it looks something like this
so we're concave upwards up to that
point
maybe actually you should
let me ignore that yellow thing i drew
before that
let me get rid of like that
so let me draw like one two three
three four point seven looks like that
and minus three four point seven one two
three
four point seven looks like that
so we know at zero
we are we have a slope of zero and we're
concave upwards so we look like this
we're concave upwards until x is equal
to three
and then at x equals three we become
concave downwards
we become concave downwards and we go
let me
drop try my best to draw it well and we
go off like that and then we're concave
upwards around zero until we get we're
concave upwards as long as x is greater
than minus three
and then at minus three we become
concave downwards again maybe i should
do it in that color this concave
downwards right here that's this right
here
that's that right there
and this concave downwards right here
sorry i meant to do it in that red color
this concave downwards right here is
this right there
and then the concave upwards around zero
is right there or you could even imagine
this concave upwards that we measured
that's this concave upwards and to this
concave upwards is that and then around
zero we're always upwards so this is my
sense of what the graph will look like
and maybe it'll just you know it turns
into well you could think about what it
does as x approaches positive or
negative infinity some of the terms well
i won't go into that but let's test
whether we've graphed grafted correctly
using a graphing calculator so let me
get out my
my ti-85 trusty tti 85 and let's graph
this sucker all right press graph
y equals it was the natural log of
x
to the fourth
plus 27.
all right i want to hit that graph there
so do second
graph
and let's cross our fingers it looks
pretty good it looks almost exactly like
what we drew so i think our i think our
our mathematics was correct so this was
actually very satisfying so hopefully
under you appreciate the usefulness of
of inflection points and second
derivatives and first derivatives when
you
in graphing some of these some of these
functions